your hand is so great you don't have a  dot on your nose yes i know that i do  because i had it no you know what it is  have you ever had the older brother the  little brother situation go on where  like you know like one guy can just  smash the other and let they just keep  going at it no that that thing on your  nose  it's [ __ ] from kissing fighter's ass  that's what it is you know the thing on  your nose is careful [ __ ] okay if i just  want to be real you hear me i like to be  real okay but they're carrying on you're  not gonna get mad  the dermatologist said stop kissing fire  our boy cody garbrandt he's fighting  i got i got my car in france when i come  back to this i want to come back  you shut up  [Laughter]  i'm a little sensitive about my [ __ ]  like burn you know what's sensitive what  fighter's [ __ ] when you kiss them  for the [ __ ] no no i'm not gonna  nah the photo [ __ ]  you